alors alors alors alors alors regarder
de quoi on va parler aujourd'hui si
aujourd'hui on va parler de ça à parler
de musique c'est les samsung galaxy botz
plus je sais pas si vous venez en 2019
c'est à dire l'année dernière samsung
avait lancé ces petits bugs lors de la
présentation de la gamme galaxy s 10 ils
ont continué leur renouveler en tout cas
le modèle cette année alors de lancement
de la gamme galaxy s 20 ça coule de
source
avec un nouveau produit ce sont les
samsung galaxy buzz plus buzz bonne
sauce qui s
les galaxies buzz plus plus parce que
modèle amélioré modèle surboosté avec
des vraies améliorations notoires dans
ces petits produits là alors le produit
même si quand on doit comme ça
d'ailleurs je vais vous montrer un ils
changent pas du tout de tête on a
exactement le même design exactement le
même bugs lorsqu'on le voit comme ça par
contre intérieur il ya des choses qui
changent et globalement c'est plutôt
bien
[Musique]
bon troisième quart est bien
révolutionnaire vous ouvrez votre étui
vous avez votre petit lait d'ici qui
vous indiquent le niveau de charge
restante vous avez vos petits bugs on a
vraiment le même design que l'année
dernière qu'on a deux petits micros
extérieur un petit micro qui se situe là
un petit micro qui se situe là il ya un
autre petit micro à l'intérieur qui vous
expliquer ça dans quelques instants
c'est très simple c'est aimante et vous
venez de positionner là dedans ils se
chargent vous refermez il c'est simple
vous allez pouvoir recharger ici en usd
celle des poils recharger sans fil en le
faisons sur un chargeur sans fil ou
alors sur la charge l'inversé de votre
smartphone notamment de votre galaxy s
vain puisque vous pouvez en plus les
avoir en précommande avec cette nouvelle
saison
ça c'est plutôt cool la boîte en
elle-même eh bien il n'y a rien de bien
révolutionnaire
à l'intérieur vous aider à trouver votre
petit logement ici pour vos galaxie buzz
à l'intérieur de quoi venir charger avec
votre câble qui est planqué là vous avez
vos différents embouts pour la taille de
vos oreilles vous invite vraiment à
venir les essayer pour trouver les
bourses ont beau que vraiment
correspondre à la taille de vos oreilles
si vous rires significativement amélioré
la qualité audio notamment au niveau des
basses
sinon c'est tout y'a pas contredire et à
rien par rapport au modèle de l'année
dernière pour l'instant il n'y a rien de
bien révolutionnaire c'est exactement la
même chose pour les nets vous le prenez
vous le mettez comme ça et vous le
tournez tac d'un petit quart de tour ça
vient se caler bien dans votre oreille
et croyez-moi ça bouge pas c'est plutôt
bien fait exactement la même chose avec
le modèle
à droite par litre a quand même fait
logique vous prenez vous faites hop un
petit quart de tour comme ça vous voulez
vissé sur l'avant et là vous les avez
dans vos oreilles sont des petits bugs
donc il dépasse légèrement
néanmoins la tenue est quand même plutôt
bonne regardez là ça marche bien alors
jusqu'au ap la tête l'air un peu con
mais franchement ça marche bien tenu et
plutôt bonne dans l'oreille alors ça
dépend une fois de plus des oreilles de
chacun mais voyez ça marche c'est bien
positionné et ça c'est assez cool
maintenant tout cas savoir sur ces
petits bugs et qui est assez cool c'est
qu'en fait vous avez pas de bouton mais
vous avez un petit pavé tactile ici en
appuyant vous allez créer des actions
comment ça marche ce truc regardez c'est
très très simple chapuis une fois ça
fait lecture ça déclenche la musique
j'appuie une deuxième fois
ça fait pose sa coupe la musique
j'appuie deux fois morceaux suivants
j'appuie trois fois morceau précédent
par contre ici vous n'avez absolument
pas la possibilité de venir régler le
volume vous pouvez pas monter vers les
eaux baissé dans le bas pour le faire il
faut vous utilisiez votre smartphone et
notamment cette année a été très cool
c'est une application qui a été
développé pour ios pouvez donc retrouver
votre application ici avec vos samsung
galaxy note plus l'application elle se
présente comme ça on vous allez voir
niveau de charge de chacun de vos
meubles ça c'est plutôt cool
vous allez au savoir le saut
environnants alors le truc que lui son
environnement c'est plutôt bien c'est à
dire que sur vos galaxie bugs vous avez
une réduction de bruit passive
c'est-à-dire grecque si buzz
ils viennent bouche et vos oreilles sur
des petits bugs il les bouches
mécaniquement ici il n'y a absolument
pas de réduction de bruit active ce qui
fait que le son extérieur ne va pas
rentrer à paris va pas rentrer il va un
peu rentré vous êtes donc pouvoir capter
un tout petit peu ce qui vient de
l'extérieur mais pas normalement et si
vous poussez la musique et bien arrive
un moment où on ne l'attendait plus
réellement ce qui se passe d'où le fait
de pouvoir amplifier le son extérieur et
c'est ce que vient faire cette
application vous pouvez donc amplifier
le son environnantes ac jeunes actives
je choisis soient j'amplifie un tout
petit peu mais pas trop
soit je l'amplifient moyennement soit
j'amplifie très fortement pour vraiment
être au courant de ce qui se passe à
côté de moi vous avez ensuite un
équaliseur de base il est positionné sur
normal je vous l'avais dit l'année
dernière profiter de la meilleure
expérience il fallait se mettre sur
dynamique
c'est toujours la même chose cette année
il ya quand même une différence au
niveau de ces petits bugs et vous
expliquer ça dans quelques instants
mais néanmoins rester sur dynamique
profiter la meilleure expérience audio
je vous développe ça dans quelques
petites secondes ensuite vous avez
petit pavé tactile ça vous explique
comment ça marche comme je voulais dire
vous appuyer une fois playes pause vous
appuyé deux fois morceau suivant vous
pouvez répondre ou terminer un appel
lorsqu'on passe un petit coup de fil à
payer trois fois morceau précédent et
applis façon prolongée bois soit refuser
un appel soit venir paramétrer
directement une action pouvait venir
ensuite verrouillé de pavé tactile et là
vous venait ensuite le paramétrer moi
j'ai vu ce soir-là parti de gauche
eh bien ça me permettait de régler mon
sons environnants donc l'activer ou le
désactiver et surmont tactile de droit
savard active et ma commande vocale à
savoir syrie puisque oui là si vous
voulez remarquez je suis sur un iphone
ensuite j'ai quelques paramètres avancés
notamment d'utiliser le son
environnement pendant les appels
jacques- où je désactive
j'ai la localisation de mes écouteurs
venir réinitialiser mes paramètres si je
le souhaite une mise à jour de logiciels
que je vous conseille de faire les
astuces et les manuels d'utilisation
soit vous explique leçon environnants ça
vous montre le niveau de batterie de
l'étui comment ça marche
l'associé à un téléphone ou à une
tablette la collection à bord galaxie
buzz voyez vous avez toutes les
informations bac sont situés là et
ensuite labour pourrait notamment avoir
un son environnement extrêmement élevé
si vous le souhaitez et puis après tout
les informations à propos de vos
écouteurs comme ça très cool qu'on est
une application ios autant plus qu elle
marche extrêmement bien ça c'est
vraiment bien pour tous les utilisateurs
d'iphone qui voulaient htc samsung
galaxy 2
c'est là plutôt dans le bon sens alors
on se dirait que normalement lorsqu'un
iphone on a plutôt l acheter des airs
potes mais néanmoins si on vous les à en
faire ou si vous voulez vraiment vous
les procurer avec votre iphone mais
sachez que vous pouvez le faire permet à
samsung de se dire ok on va étendre
notre marché on va aller au delà des
utilisateurs de samsung au delà des
utilisateurs d'ordre aux ide on va venir
draguer les utilisateurs d'iphone dont
bon pourquoi pas sur tout cas une bonne
stratégie
[Musique]
il faut comprendre de la qualité audio
n'est pas ici mais qui n'a pas pas là
voilà vous bougez pas parlant justement
la qualité audio c'est le point le plus
intéressant je dirais avec ses écouteurs
bien évidemment quand on parle de
musique on parle avant tout de qualité
audio on parle également d'expérience
mais là il ya en tout cas s'intéresse
cette fois ci ils ont mis deux
transducteurs par oreille c'est à dire
que vous allez avoir une partie qui va
s'occuper des aigus médiums aigus et une
partie qui va s'occuper des graves vous
savez grand rodez c'est la différence
par rapport aux modèles de l'année
dernière vous n'en aviez qu'un seul qui
allait faire le job ça permet de séparer
les canaux ça permet d'avoir une
meilleure qualité
parce qu'il me permet d'avoir une
meilleure qualité audio
néanmoins lors que vous prenez vos
petits écouteurs faut que tu buzz
il vous les mettez dans vos oreilles que
vous lancez la musique et bien
l'expérience audio est assez petit assez
serré assez étriqués je peux pas dire
que le son est pas bon mais les
fréquences sont assez médium pour venir
ouvrir le sont rajoutés de la
spatialisation du corps que ça groove et
que son viennent vraiment intéressant
faut faire exactement la même chose que
l'année dernière
vous êtes dans votre application vous
mettez votre équaliseur sont dynamiques
et là ça va venir ouvrir
significativement breton ça vient
élargir le spectre vous allez récupérer
beaucoup plus de grave ça va venir orner
davantage ça va rajouter beaucoup plus
de précisions sur les médiums aigus et
sur les aigus ça vient casser un petit
peu les médiums
je trouve que le son est un peu plus dur
mais ça fait tâche moi ce que je vous
conseille pour vraiment vire optimiser
l'expérience audio ses dunes de calais
vos équaliseur d'autres applications
sont dynamiques et de deux d'utiliser
les coins l'isr d'une application tierce
que vous allez utiliser pour goûter de
la musique pour venir ensuite réglé
peaufiner les réglages en fonction de ce
que vous aimez retour une petite des
musiques que vous allez écouter la
fonction de votre oreille
moi par exemple ce que je fais je viens
monter un tout petit peu les fréquences
graves pour ajouter encore un peu plus
de corps est pas un moment reçu des
morceaux je vais rajouter un peu de
médium que je trouve un petit peu trop
cassé par le mode dynamique
maintenant il faut que je trouve dommage
sur ces bugs vu qu'on est quand même au
tarif de 69 euros bank 169 euros ce
n'est pas donc une petite somme et bien
vous n'avez pas de ld
et vous n'avez pas non plus
compatibilité à ptx qu'en est-il
concernant la latence alors on a une
toute petite latence elles existent peut
pas dire qu'il n'existe pas ce serait
vous mentir
il y a une petite latence qui
personnellement ne va pas déranger ou
que vous allez regarder des vidéos sur
internet
elle est très minime ça ne pose
absolument aucun problème mais elle
existe samsung nous vante une bonne
qualité d'appel grâce aux trois micros
de micro à l'extérieur pour dire capter
les bruits ambiants et un micro à
l'intérieur tout ça va venir travailler
en ce sens pourra optimiser complètement
le son de votre voix pour bien capter et
un petit peut réduire le bruit extérieur
attention une fois de plus il n'y a pas
de réduction de bruit active
là dessus on parle vraiment d'une
réduction de bruit passif et donc une
réduction de bruit mécanique parce qu'on
vient boucher vos oreilles faut vraiment
le savoir eh bien pour moi la qualité
des appels là-dessus n'est pas au rendez
vous sa coupe c'est pas terrible
mes interlocuteurs me zen et tu appelles
adéquat sentant pas bien j'ai dû
switcher prendre mon téléphone à la main
et à tout ça allait beaucoup mieux donc
si vous voulez c'est cette galaxie botz
plus pour passer des coups de fil et
bien mon avis là dessus
la mission sera pas remplie maintenant
il ya un point qui était vraiment mal y
aurait par rapport à la génération de
l'année dernière et bien c'est
l'autonomie samsung nous annonce 11
heures avec vos petits bugs pour ajouter
de la musique et jusqu'à 22 heures avec
le boîtier de recharge c'est quand même
beaucoup plus que l'année dernière ce
qui est vraiment bien je peux pas
vraiment vous dire 11 heures j'ai pas
calculer mais les par une seconde par
seconde mais je pense que 10 heures on y
arrive sans soucis donc ça c'est
vraiment cool so permet de pousser
beaucoup plus loin votre musique de
l'est beaucoup tu es beau couple autant
je me perds toujours à savoir le kenya
le quai ça c'est le left l'artac
m'arrête
voilà donc ça c'est plutôt bien pour
pousser l'expérience au maximum et aller
le plus loin possible et il faut savoir
que en trois minutes de chasse vous
partez pour une heure de musique
attention pas en charge à induction en
charge filaire autre petit encas
connaître sur ces écouteurs lorsque vous
les prenez et que vous les enlevez en
même temps eh bien ça vient couper la
musique par contre le fait que lorsque
vous enlevez les deux puisque si vous ne
l'enlevez qu'un seul regard des hommes
je prends je remets la musique parce
qu'elles étaient coupées j'en enlève
qu'un seul et bien hop je garde la
musique dans mon oreille droite ça
aurait été bien que ça puisse la coupe
est effectivement parce que lorsque
quelqu'un vient me parler et bien je
l'entends parler mais c'est toujours la
musique n'ont ils vraiment que j'enlève
les deux ce sont des petits écouteurs
qui sont résistants à la sueur pas du
tout à l'eau et à la poussière on est
ici une certification ip etc
2 ils ont une bonne tenue maintenant je
sais pas si c'est parfait pour aller
faire du sport en extérieur ça dépend
vraiment de vous ça dépend de votre
sport ça dépend de ce que vous en faites
la tenue qu'elle est plutôt pas mal
est-ce que vous pensez que vous pourriez
aller faire du footing avait dit que moi
je ne suis pas allé courir je suis pas
quelqu'un qui croie particules à manger
plus quelqu'un qui nage mais je ne me
vois pas aller l'ajax à ce en quoi je
serai bien évidemment de les casser ces
petits galaxie buzz des existe en blanc
comme ça il existe également en noir et
en bleu ils sont disponibles à dès
maintenant au tarif de 169 euros
d'ailleurs s'il vous intéresse je vous
ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description alors attention parce que
maintenant ça soulève beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de questions puisque vous savez
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui se
développe énormément tout le monde fait
ses petits bugs fait ces écouteurs
chaque marque propose sa solution à tel
point maintenant qu'il ya pléthore de
produits sur le marché et qu'on ne sait
plus réellement et qu'elle est ya pis si
samsung un avantage c'est qu'il y ait
écrit samsung et que ça me choque c'est
extrêmement connue mais maintenant il ya
tellement de produits qui existent sans
marché que ce soit et free bird 3 doigts
mais que ce soit les repose la police
pro d'apple
j'en passe et des meilleures du côté de
chez plantronics pauli a travaillé il ya
beaucoup de monde qui existe beaucoup de
monde sans marcher donc à la question
faut-il htc samsung galaxy bugs plus au
tarif 269 euros et bien ça devient un
peu compliqué parce qu'ils n'offrent est
tellement large qu'on sait pas
réellement comment se positionner alors
pour moi le premier point qui la
permettent vraiment de vous aider dans
votre décision c est ce que vous aimez
le système de beule ce qui vient rentrer
dans votre oreille qui est réduction de
bruit passive et pas du tout active est
ce que vous aimez ce système là où s et
contrario préféré le système der pol ce
qui viennent se poser sur vos oreilles
la différence elle va vraiment se faire
là dessus sur le confort sur le fait de
préférer des bugs ou pas là-dessus la
tenue est bonne la qualité et bols
l'audio et bien l'autonomie est bonne
donc le produit est globalement
franchement bien moi je trouve
intéressant donc si vous aimez samzun si
vous aimez le son à kg et si ce format
vous plaît et 669 euros ça nous fait pas
peur et bien vous pouvez y aller les
samsung galaxy bugs plus les c'est dur à
dire c'est moi qui réponds c'est dur les
samsung galaxy buzz plus sont cool
a vous de me dire maintenant ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire qu'est
ce que vous avez comme écouteurs comme
deux aires pose quelle est la solution
que vous utilisez et est ce que samsung
est est ce que ces samsung galaxy meuse
plus peuvent vous tentez oui non vous
marquez tout ça on va en comment sarko
t'as nous on se retrouve dès demain
pour continuer à parler tecate nous
emballe d'amour du bisou à damon seul
[Musique]